I'm an infectious disease epidemiologist
at Kent State university in Ohio.
I mostly work on what are called
zoonotic diseases
so those are diseases that are
transmitted between animals
and people and earlier this week I wrote
a column for Quanta Magazine about
how our existing knowledge of
coronaviruses can
potentially help us inform, knowing
and understanding what's going on with
the COVID-19 pandemic.
And so I'm here today on the Quanta
Magazine
YouTube channel to answer some
additional questions that have come
in on social media, in the comments of
that article
and elsewhere and there is a
function where you can also ask
questions during the talk and those will
be relayed to me.
So I guess I'll answer as many of those
as possible.
And I will get started with a few that
already came in
from various locations already. So one
question:
Does immunity conferred from
infection
by a cold coronavirus -- so there are four
other types of coronaviruses that cause
kind of the common cold
in humans that have been identified
previously --
so does immunity to these provide
prophylaxis or I guess immunity to
COVID-19?
And is anyone asking asymptomatic or
immune cases about recent cold
Infections?
And the answer is, I mean we're not
100 percent
sure but probably not. There doesn't seem
to be a lot of
cross-protective immunity between
the various
coronavirus species and even
when immunity develops it seems to wane
relatively
quickly. So that's looking at both
patients who had had SARS, kind of the
original SARS from 2002 and 2003
and following those over time, at least
the antibody response
seemed to drop off pretty dramatically
over
a period of about one to three years.
Looking at some of the other human
coronaviruses, the common cold
coronavirus,
that immunity also seems to wane
relatively quickly, so
you would have to have had a cold
relatively recently which is one of the
things that they asked, are people asking
if they've had colds? And I don't know
any studies that are
doing that currently but you would have
to do more than just ask about colds.
What you would really want to do
is to set up a study to sample
people over time and not only ask about
colds because those can be caused --
the common cold
only about 20 percent of those are caused by
coronaviruses so the other
80 percent or so are other types of viruses that
would not be protective.
So what you want to do is really
sample over time
and look at people who are getting those
common cold viruses
and then look at if they are able to be
infected with
SARS coronavirus 2. A problem with doing
that right now of course is that
our testing supplies are very limited.
Even things like you know PPE,
personal protective equipment for people
who are doing the sampling, the swabs
that we use to do the sampling
are also in short supply, so that type of
study
would be difficult to do right now to
get any kind of definitive answers but
I guarantee people are probably looking
at those types of things in other animal
models
and other aspects as well. So that is
definitely something that's on people's
minds.
And one thing I wanted to add with that
was that's also kind of one
hypothesis that's been put forward
regarding why kids may not be as
seriously infected with this,
may not have symptoms that are as
serious
as adults get. You know kids
are germy and may have
more colds from coronaviruses more
recently than adults have,
so that's another thing that's being
investigated,
although I don't know, you know, I know
it's been
bounced around the research
community, so I know it's on people's
minds.
All right some other ones, let's see.
All right. In the realm of
neurological changes
and the search for characteristic
symptoms which might be easier to
detect
than loss of taste and smell
has anyone thought to look for changes
in hearing,
maybe loss of upper octaves?
I don't know about that. That's
really interesting but
I don't know that that would necessarily
be easier to detect,
because you do have to have equipment
to do that, and it also helps to have
like a before and after to know
if before coronavirus infection people
were able to detect those
upper octaves anyway, because of course
that's something that
many adults lose over time just from
being around loud noises and going to
concerts and things like that.
I have not seen any evidence that the
virus
affects nerves of the auditory system.
With the olfactory system we do know
that
this virus and other coronavirus as well
can
enter through olfactory nerves and
can affect some of the tissue around
those and may
cause kind of pathology in that
manner and that may be what
causes loss of sense and tastes but
we're not even sure of that yet.
So I think there's a whole lot of
open questions around
those neurological issues with
with SARS coronavirus too
that are still really big unknowns and I
haven't seen anything regarding
hearing for that.
All right. Twitter. So
I have a question, if the coronavirus
family has a low rate of mutations
why has it been so difficult to make a
vaccine? And this is from Becca O.
The motifs and structures in them are
relatively conserved and why are they
not
very immunogenic? And so for
vaccines there are a whole lot of
things that really
need to come together to create
an effective and safe vaccine. And so
one of them is the mutation rate,
obviously if something mutates really
quickly like influenza,
it makes it more difficult to create a
vaccine because
it mutates around that, and so you
have to update it frequently.
But that's not the only issue. So you
have to find you know good antigens,
ones that will generate
a robust immune response and ones that
will not you know harm the host.
That’s been you know the challenge
with this.
So we do have a good target antigen
in
the spike protein. So this is the one
that is used
by the virus to attach to host cells.
And so there was a lot of work on this
in the SARS
era. So when that virus was recognized
and its kind of pathogenic properties
were realized and
and we saw how harmful this could be
there was a big infusion
in funding for vaccines for
for SARS coronavirus. And so there are a
lot of groups working on it and a lot of
them had some candidate vaccines that
ended up getting tested,
some in animal models. But then
you know SARS went away and we were
able to contain it.
And with the other serious human
coronavirus, MERS coronavirus,
it really hasn't created the kinds of
epidemics
that that SARS did, so there was just
kind of a loss
of interest in coronavirus vaccines
for you know maybe like 2008
till basically the present. So a lot
of
things got developed and then never
followed up on. So that's one big problem
is that they just never got
into you know robust human tests for
safety and efficacy. We were just never
able to do those with the previous
candidates. So they're there but one
of the other problems potentially was
that when they used the whole
protein so the entire protein they did
find
that in some cases it seemed to cause
more harm to some of the vaccinated
animals than protection.
And so this was through a mechanism
called antibody dependent enhancement.
We see this with some other viral
diseases, most notably dengue virus
where if you're infected once and then
infected again with a different strain
of dengue
you're actually more likely to have
severe outcomes, to get dengue
hemorrhagic fever
than those who had only been
infected once.
So those antibodies don't necessarily
protect you they can actually
enhance the ability of the virus to
potentially enter host cells and
and a number of other things that
lead to a more severe
outcome the second time you're infected.
So they saw that with some of these
candidate vaccines and so
instead of using the whole spike
protein they have kind of
chopped it up to look at the
smallest piece that is both
you know effective as an antigen
but doesn't cause this kind of antibody
dependent enhancement. So
that's what they're doing for most of
the candidate vaccines, is some
pieces or parts of the spike
protein. And I would will say that there
are about a hundred different
vaccine candidates that are in some form
of development right now so there's a
lot of them out there.
So it's really been just that we
kind of lost a lot of that work
in the last decade or so and now
we're trying to play catch-up
in you know a period of three months or so.
So it's not that necessarily we
don't know that we,
you know that's super difficult to make
or that we can't make one, or that we
really failed in the past it's just that
we have stopped in the past because
we didn't have much reason to
to go on. So I think there's a lot of
hope that we will be able to create a
vaccine for this but
it's just kind of overcoming some
of those challenges
where we left off previously. And now you
have to pick up those research programs
almost from scratch.
All right.
So let's see, so this is from YouTube.
So can't social distancing only work
if we keep that going until we get a
vaccine?
Assuming we stopped social
distancing before a vaccine, aren’t we just
going to get a second wave
until we hit herd immunity, and therefore
social distancing didn't actually do
anything?
So that's one of the things that we're
working out right now.
So what we've done so far, there is
evidence that social distancing in the
United States
and elsewhere has worked pretty well,
that we have slowed down the spread of
This.
It's estimated that across the United
States
the basic reproductive number right now
averaging again everything is
right about at one.
So that means that on average
each person who is infected spreads it
to one other person so this is better
than
what it was initially in the outbreak,
which is estimated to be
around three. And this is because
most people are doing this
social distancing, most
areas have implemented that. But
a couple things. That means one it's
still spreading even if the
reproductive
number is lower it still is not
extinguished, because
on average still each person is
spreading it to at least one other
person which means it will continue to
to spread even if it's slower than it
would have spread
you know in March. And
sorry my dogs are running outside and
distracting me.
And so it means it is still
spreading and then of course some states
are reopening so Georgia, Texas others
are loosening some of their restrictions
on some of these social gatherings and
opening up
you know hair salons and tattoo
parlors and
restaurants in some cases. So you do have
that
potential for additional cases from that
right.
So as
public health experts what we would
really like
is to move from the mitigation
standpoint which is basically where
we're just trying
to keep this at a level where it doesn't
overwhelm our hospital systems
where you know we can keep people
alive if they are seriously ill where we
have enough medical professionals to
deal with this and enough hospital beds
and things like that which we've
pretty well pretty much done so far,
to going back to a containment strategy
and so for that
you need to be able to test people.
Right now there are very few areas that
can test people
with more mild infections.
Most of the tests are still done on
people with more serious infections
and also on healthcare workers who need
to know if they are
are positive for COVID-19
and they would have to take time off
off work
and not be around patients. So that's
where most of the tests are going right
now.
What we really need is more tests so we
can test anyone who has symptoms
and isolate individuals who are
positive and then find out who they have
been exposed to
over the last you know five or seven
days
and put them into quarantine so that
you can basically stop the spread of
this virus by getting infected people
out of society for a brief time until
they're no longer infectious
and keeping those who have been exposed
from spreading the virus before they
become symptomatic
before they even realize they're
Infected. So that's what like South Korea
has done, basically that's been their
model,
is this test trace isolate.
But right now, we just we don't have the
ability to do that, we don't have the
tests we don't have as I mentioned
before
personal protective equipment for people
who are doing the tests to keep them
safe while they're
taking samples. We don't have the
ability to turn this around rapidly.
You know one of the things that we
really need is to be able to take a test
and get people their results really
quickly which we don't
have right now and then
having this kind of mass quarantine, I
mean not of the whole population but of
individuals who have been exposed
also is logistically difficult.
So that needs to have a really good
protocol in place
and we don't have any of that so
that's still what we're hoping for.
You know no one wants to
stay in
in kind of a stay at home a lockdown
situation for the next
you know two years or whatever until
potentially we have an effective vaccine.
But you know what you're going to be
doing is if you
relax those social distancing measures
then yes, you're probably going to see
another
increase in cases and then you probably
have to restrict those measures again
and
do this over and over which um I don't
think is good for
you know for society for mental health
for any of this,
so so I’m hopeful that still at some
point we can
ramp up that that testing and do that
instead of being in just this kind of
full society
mitigation effects until hopefully we
we do get a vaccine
at some point. All right.
So, let's see for our next questions here…
All right
So, if we do get a vaccine and if
reinfection after a year is possible -- this
is from the Quanta
comment section -- then even the best
vaccine will have to be given every year.
So that's a question from Ted.
And we don't know. Again, it depends on
what ends up
being the vaccine that kind of makes
it to the finish line first or
the one that ends up being most
effective
and with 100 candidates out there
it's really hard to say what that is
going to be right now.
So most vaccines you know are based on
the model of immunity that
the host would have naturally
but there are ways to kind of tweak that.
So
you can in some cases conjugate
additional proteins to the main
antigen
of the virus and make the immune
response stronger
for example. We do this with some of
the bacterial
vaccines that makes them
last longer
and makes them a little bit more robust
so there may be potential for that.
There may be potential to put this
into kind of live vectors,
not the live virus, it's not the live
coronavirus but
other viruses that can replicate in the
body
and kind of introduce the body to maybe
pieces and parts of that spike protein
as I mentioned before.
That may be more antigenic so we
just don't really know it
may be something that would have to be
boosted every year,
we don't know at this point. But it
may also be that
you know even if immunity does wane
after
a year or who knows it may be that
future infections are still more mild
than the original one
so even if you don't have kind of
complete you know protective
antibody titers it might be enough to
keep you from getting a serious
infection and then
that might be all we care about. You
know you might not have to get
revaccinated so
there are a ton of open questions about
that right now and honestly there's
more questions than answers so
yeah so,
unfortunately, I just have to say we just
really don't
know right now. All right.
Let's see.
From YouTube live from Molly Given.
How likely is it that we will discover a
really powerful drug that cures
COVID-19 quickly before a vaccine
gets licensed for widespread use?
That’s a good question. I just did
an article
for another outlet looking at some of
the drugs that are being used
and for most of those drugs, not all
but most
that are being examined for treatment
for COVID-19, a lot of them are
already in use
for other infections or other
areas. So if we could find something
that
is effective and it has already been
licensed for
something else, it's already known to be
you know relatively safe
and has already gone through all the
approvals it's much easier to take those
and kind of repurpose them
for treatment for COVID-19 than it is
to develop something completely de novo
where you have to
you know determine its safety profile
and everything else.
So if we find one of those that are
already approved for other
infections or other conditions then yes
I think
that those could be in place before
we get to a vaccine.
But from you know the tests we've seen
so far and of course there are many that
are ongoing so
who knows what the outcome of those
will be too,
I haven't been particularly impressed
with the results that we've seen so
far. We saw
the results from some of the Remdesivir
trials the other day,
and the ones in China really didn't
go anywhere.
The NIH ones that were done here in the
United States seem to
maybe show some progress but that's also
an IV drug which makes it just a lot
more difficult
to get to a larger number of people,
especially because it seems that one
really might be better
if used early but you know if you have a
person with
mild symptoms
are you going to give them an IV drug
and how is that going to be used? So
I think there are a lot of a lot
of issues that need to be worked
out
and of course, a lot of other drugs are
under investigation,
so it kind of depends on if those
are already approved
and could just be kind of co-opted for
COVID-19 or if they're completely new
and need to go through those studies
which would take longer.
All right.
Let's see.
Some of these I've kind of already
addressed, so one was also from the
Quanta comments section asking about
From Jessica Fay Harrison do you expect
that any of the current vaccines in
development could interact
with SARS-COVID-2 in vivo to produce an
increase in in pathogenicity
by an antibody dependent enhancement
type of mechanism? So
I discussed that a little bit, but
that's definitely one thing that they're
actively looking for and trying to avoid.
So, they know they've seen that in
previous SARS
vaccines and animal models. So right
now we have some
vaccines that are already in
testing phase in humans.
And so phase one trials are for
Safety, so that's the first thing that
they're doing.
So we have one already from the NIH
which is
a MRNA vaccine so they actually inject
the
MRNA rather than the protein itself and
then the body produces the protein.
So that's one that is again already
in these phase one safety trials so that
I guarantee that's one of the
the things that they will be looking for
in these volunteers,
is those types of reactions
once they re-challenge with the
vaccine.
I know the
vaccine developers are very cognizant of
that.
So
I don't think any of the final ones
would
end up with that type of reaction just
because they're looking for that so
carefully but
you know once you have this in a
large group of people even if that's
something that's a one in a million
reaction
you're really not going to know if
that happens until you have
a large number of people using it so
that is something that I guarantee will
be
tracked very closely for any of these
vaccines. Once any kind of get into
into production potentially um
and then to kind of go along with that
from OS on the live
YouTube chat here how long will it take
to create a vaccine and then why does it
take so long?
So we don't know how long it
will take.
You know the time that has been
usually cited is 12 to 18 months. I think
that's optimistic.
Most vaccines take
more on the
timeline of at least a decade and some
many more.
So I work in my laboratory with a
bacterium called staphylococcus aureus
and you know some of you may have had it,
it causes
skin infections but it can also cause
really serious disease including
Bacteremia, pneumonia and death.
And we don't have a vaccine for that. We
have tried
since at least the 1950s maybe before
looking for different candidates
different antigens
that would be appropriate for a vaccine
and we don't have one yet.
Now it's a bacterium and not a virus so
there are some differences but
even for some viral diseases for HIV we
don't have a vaccine for
RSV respiratory syncytial virus that
causes
serious infections in infants especially
in pre-term infants
we don't have a vaccine and one of the
reasons for that is also
one of the tested vaccines caused
antibody dependent enhancements
similar to what they've seen in some of
the animal models for SARS vaccines.
So just creating a vaccine
is really a little bit of an art and
a lot of luck
in addition to the science so
I'm hoping you know I'm
optimistic,
I hope that we could have one in that
12 to 18-month timeline but
I'm also a realist and I'm not
counting on it. So I'm certainly not
you know putting anything in to
bet that we will have one on that
timeline.
And you know of course we want to make
sure these are safe
most importantly so right now as I
mentioned there are
at least the one vaccine and I think
one other that are in these phase one
trials. So you look at safety first
and then you do another trial with
slightly large larger group of people
where you look at safety and you can
start to look at
if they actually work, you know are
people producing an antibody response
and then usually with phase three you
start to introduce it to
a large group of people and then you see
if it actually protects them against
disease.
So you need a large group of
people to do that
in and then you need to see if it
actually protects them from getting
you know infected with SARS
coronavirus 2.
To kind of ramp that up and make that a
little bit quicker
some people are suggesting human
challenge studies for that third part so
that you would actually
you know vaccinate people with the
candidate vaccine
and then expose them
purposely to SARS coronavirus 2 to see
if it protects them or not.
So that's being proposed. There are a
lot of issues with that, a lot of
people who support it a lot of people
who don't, who
are concerned about the ethics of
that especially when we don't have a
treatment
and when it seems to do some weird
things even in people that are
would be good challenge subjects like
those who are young and healthy and have
no real risk factors.
So it always is dependent on
how some of these trials go. If
everything works great in the first you
know
first phases,
18 months I think is possible but
then that remember that is
till we get a functional vaccine,
and that's only kind of the start of it
in some ways. Then you have to
make enough doses of that to give to the
population
and it may be something where you need
multiple doses
to have a really effective immune
response, so each individual may need two
or three doses to be completely
protected. Okay well just the United
States alone there you're talking you
know
almost a billion doses um if everybody
would need three.
So you have to have you know
factories and things that can
manufacture that
and those don't just spring up
overnight so
you either have to start working on
that now or you have to co-opt
that from facilities that are already
making vaccines.
And then do you end up with a
shortage of other critical vaccines
because you've
devoted that time and
that area to making vaccines for
coronavirus?
so again there's a lot of logistical
challenges even after you have
a vaccine that may be scientifically
tenable.
Then you still have to get it produced,
you still have to get that out to the
population which is going to take
you know if you say 18 months for
an approved vaccine I mean at least
another probably six months
or more depending on what type of
vaccine
it is and if we have the facilities that
can do it,
to really get that ramped up and kind
of
out to the population to protect them.
So
yes long answer for maybe
18 months to two years I think to be
optimistic.
All right there's other ones.
From Brian in the Quanta comment
section: what are the medium term
prospects of a general solution to viral
Infections? So
short term obviously is just kind of
social distancing what we're doing now
which again I don't think is a
tenable long-term solution. Long-term
solution would be something like a
vaccine.
So medium-term I think would be you
know if we can get something to treat it,
some of those drugs that work
but one of the other interesting things
that again is
still in a gray area still being
Investigated,
but some people are looking at the
potential of
other live vaccines
as a way to kind of almost
I hate to say boost the immune system
because that's really not scientific but
a way to provide kind of broad
general protective
innate immunity we think against a
variety of pathogens.
So you may have seen some of the
studies looking at, or some of the
really suggestions, not a lot of
studies so far,
but the suggestions that the BCG
vaccine
so a vaccine against tuberculosis that
is not used
routinely in the United States but is
used in some other countries,
that individuals who are vaccinated with
that
may have some resistance
to being infected with SARS
coronavirus.
There's also kind of similar ideas
about that with the MMR
vaccine so measles mumps rubella
looking mostly at the rubella part of
that as
maybe something that is maybe generating
some protection there.
So
whether those will actually pan out I
don't know because there's a lot
of confounding issues in there,
for the BCG vaccine that's
primarily used again not only but
primarily used in developing countries
who may not have
testing for coronavirus that is
really
adequate so maybe we're just missing
some cases. Maybe there are other
factors that are going into
this,
rather than just the BCG vaccine.
For MMR one of the reasons they're
looking at that is again
with this aspect of children having
you know much more mild symptoms are
being completely asymptomatic
and wondering if that's because that
they have
higher levels of immunity to
to MMR because they've been exposed to
that more recently than most of us
adults.
So those are really just kind of
hypothesis generating right now but
people are looking into those and I
think there was an article out maybe
today
in the New York Times on some of that
work and some of the rationale behind
that.
So if we could find that some of those
work that would be fantastic so then we
could just
you know give those to
populations and
you know even if they don't work
specifically against coronavirus if they
could be protective
you know at least to help the
population kind of
reduce transmission of
coronavirus or reduce the severity of
symptoms
those could potentially help in that
kind of gap that we have
between now and development of a
specific coronavirus vaccine.
So keep your eye on those, it may
completely fade out and may be
junk there may be nothing to
back it up but
those are some areas where people are at
least looking right now.
All right let's see here.
All right so if I'm
skipping over your question
I’m sorry it's probably because I just
maybe don't know enough or
maybe it's more for a kind of clinician
or something than myself. Like there's
one sorry from
from Leonardo: do anticoagulants work to
treat the respiratory symptoms?
And I have no idea. That's a great
question, I don't know I'm
sorry.
Sorry Leonardo.
From Dean Morrison: A lot of health
care workers are dying
from COVID. Statistically speaking could
this be because of higher original
exposure?
Maybe. So that's one of the things
I talked about in
the article for
some other coronaviruses where they've
tested them again mostly in animal
models
they have seen that a higher initial
dose
of exposure does seem to lead to more
serious
infections and so with healthcare
workers especially again if they're not
being supplied with adequate PPE
and they're working with
patients that are sick you know more of
them that may be expelling
higher levels of virus, that may be doing
procedures where the virus becomes
aerosolized,
so it's easier to breathe in,
that's one of the hypotheses for the
reasons why some of these healthcare
workers are coming down with
not only illness but in some cases
really severe illness even though
they're otherwise seem to be kind of
young and healthy,
is that exposure to a higher
load of virus and especially a higher
load of aerosolized virus.
They also did see this with SARS
especially in the early days before
it was recognized and
before measures were taken to
really use like n95 respirators and
things like that to protect health care
workers,
that there did seem to be kind of a dose
exposure there, that
more virus you were exposed to more
severe symptoms you could get.
And we have a little bit of evidence of
that from the early days in China.
Also again
when healthcare workers were exposed to
this before understanding what it was.
That using
again n95 respirators and face
masks and things like that to
protect health care workers
did seem to decrease their mortality
and
incidents of serious infection from that
as well. So
we think maybe again you know that's
something that will be
better resolved with good animal models
and animal experiments
where you can directly challenge them
with different doses of the virus and
look at the severity of their outcomes.
So that's something that I'm sure
will be coming from some of these
animal studies and on
that line JCG856
Asked: how good do you think the animal
models being used are? And again that's
one
a little too far out of my area. I do
know some of the biologists who are
working on this
but I'm not sure what their thoughts
are on the animal models. There are a lot
of different ones being used
too. I mean from you know your typical
kind of
rodents to other things
so I don't know if we know yet and I
should mention that
that's one of the issues with studying
this is that
at least in the United States and I’m
pretty sure this is
common around the world though not
completely
100 percent dealt with the same way
but using live stars coronavirus 2
in a lab in the United States you have
to have that in a BSL-3 laboratory.
So there are different levels of
biosafety
that are required for different
pathogens. So something like Ebola is a
BSL-4
pathogen so this one is a BSL-3
which
there are not really that many BSL-3
laboratories in the United States.
my laboratory is a BSL-2 so I could work
with
coronavirus you know just RNA but not
actual infectious
virus. I couldn't do you know any growing
up of the virus in my lab or
any animal studies anywhere on our
campus because we don't have a BSL-3
laboratory
so those are kind of rare and trying to
do
all of the studies that everyone wants
done with this coronavirus
is difficult and challenging because
it's hard to work in in those
environments. You get tired
you have to wear all of the gear
and the
respirators and things like that so it
makes working with these viruses
rather difficult and so while we all
want some of these answers
like now like yesterday it just is
difficult because
of the limited number of BSL-3
labs and also because of the limited
number
of people with real expertise in
coronaviruses.
Because as I mentioned earlier you know
funding has waxed and waned for these
and so to have a real bona fide
coronavirus researcher who
has done this for years there's only
you know a handful of those maybe.
So we are having a lot of people who
have expertise
in other viruses now moving into
coronaviruses but there's still that
dearth of lab space so it's making it
really difficult
to get at some of these answers maybe as
soon as we would like.
All right from the Quanta comment
section
from Rad: if both SARS one
coronavirus
SARS coronavirus 1 and coronavirus
2 enter cells via Ace2 receptors
which I talked about in a previous
Quanta
article that you can search on the
website, why is it that only COVID-19
impacts the upper respiratory tract?
And so the answer for that is again we
don't 100 percent know.
And so that's one of the things that would be
really great to be looked at in some of
those animal models
but for one it's
I should say that it's a spectrum so
you can have some of the other
coronavirus 1 in the upper respiratory
tract.
It's not like it's all or
nothing
but SARS 2 does seem to be
much more prominent in the upper
respiratory tract and SARS coronavirus 1
in the lower respiratory tract so
that's
one of the reasons why we think SARS
2 is more transmissible person to
person because of all that upper
respiratory tract replication
whereas SARS original was more deadly
because of that lower respiratory tract
infection
but less transmissible. But the exact
reasons
aren't 100 percent clear.
And just because they use the same
receptor doesn't mean they bind to it
with the same affinity so that seems to
be one thing, is that
oh no and I'm probably going to mess
this up
I want to say SARS coronavirus 2
binds to it more strongly
I would have to double check that I'm
sorry um
but so there can be differences
in binding affinities and also it's not
just the binding
of the virus to the receptor, that's kind
of
like step one but there are other things
that happen as well.
So there are different proteases,
infusion proteins and things like that
that
also lead to you know really
allowing this virus to
to replicate inside the cell so there
can be differences in those as well that
affect kind of locations
of tissue tropism and things like that
that.
I don't think we know all of
those answers right now
and exactly why those are different. They
both also seem to again
at least be able to bind to cells in the
GI tract but
aren't necessarily a GI infection even
though they can cause some
gastrointestinal symptoms so that's also
you know we don't 100 percent understand all of
that either,
so those are some of the things
again that once I think we have some of
those good established animal models
and virologists to work on them and lab
space to do that in
that we'll start to see some of the
answers to some of those questions come
out.
Because I think they're still kind of
unresolved even though I think a lot of
people have different ideas
about what that might be.
Let's see.
All right so from the YouTube
live chat: so bats host a lot of
coronaviruses, is there something we can
learn from the way bats’ immune systems
handle the virus? And that is kind of a
million-dollar question too that's
something that's
you know a lot of people have wanted
to know because
bats harbor not only you know
coronaviruses
but are hosts to
viruses like Ebola and Marburg, Nipah and
Hendra
you know all kinds of rabies, you know
a lot of different pathogens come from
bats and part of that is because
I mean bats just are incredibly diverse.
They're
you know we have so many different
species of bats
that it's not surprising that we get a
lot of spillovers because they just
harbor
their own different
viral groups and then those eventually
can
cause infections in humans. So why don't
they seem
to cause harm to bats? We
don't really know.
So there's a paper out I mean maybe
a decade or 15 years ago
that tried to review the literature on
bat immune systems. And at that point
there was almost nothing that was out
there.
I mean bats are really hard to work with
in the laboratory, they don't really
survive well in captivity
so it makes it difficult to do a lot
of experimental work on them so
sometimes what we have to do is
more observational data or
you know things like that so it's
difficult to really
know precisely why all of that is
different.
There's also been some suggestion
that
just because of the way bats you know
live
that they fly, they have to have a
high metabolism so that they can
you know expend that energy on flight,
that may also play a role in their
immune system if basically they're
you know fevered all the time,
essentially they have a high body
temperature then maybe that is just kind
of keeping
the viruses that they have in check.
So that they don't
you know stick in the bats
themselves but
those are all really more hypotheses
than anything because again they're just
really difficult
to test because we don't have a lot of
of
good experimental data on some of the
Bats. So
a good question that I unfortunately
am not able to provide a great answer
for.
All right from Paul Gildan:
how definitive of COVID-19 are the
chills and shakes if these symptoms
occur
only sporadically over a few days? And
yeah I wish I could tell you. We don't
know.
I mean that's one of the things with
all the symptoms, is that
one we're seeing kind of an expanding
case definition of what are included as
far as COVID19 symptoms we just saw the
CDC added some
additional ones the other day and
even so
some of those are still pretty
nonspecific I mean cold and chills,
it could be potentially covered 19 it
could be
influenza that's still circulating
depending on where you are, it could be
you know a number of other respiratory
viruses so
we don't know and that's one of the
problems with again lacking really good
testing especially some kind of a rapid
test
or a point of care diagnostic like you
do for flu and you can
you know get your results in 20 minutes
so
without those, yeah we really can't say
definitively because those are so
non-specific and you know could be
anything from flu to food poisoning.
So yeah we just don't know yet.
From Inkits:
How long will it take to develop herd
Immunity?
And that's another good question that
we don't know.
When you look at the percent of the
population
that will need to be infected by any
kind of virus to develop herd immunity
that is based on how transmissible they
are in a population.
So with this one again assuming an R0
of three
okay you would have to have
basically about sixty percent, sixty to
seventy percent of the population
immune in order to reach that herd
immunity threshold.
Okay now remember herd immunity is not
like a switch, it's not all or nothing,
the higher number of people
that you have in the population that are
immune
the more difficult it makes for that
virus to
find a susceptible host and to spread so
you know
any immunity in the population is better
than none even if it's not kind of at
that herd immunity threshold yet.
But for this again because we have so
many open questions about immunity we
just don't know.
So if we would
go over the course of say you know 12
months all right
and 40 percent of the population would have been
infected
with SARS coronavirus 2
in theory 40 of the population then
would be immune.
But what if that immunity wanes after a
year so you have the people who were
infected at the very beginning
have maybe you know are maybe no longer
functionally
immune so you're not really at 40 percent of the
population anymore,
you're at a lower level than that. So
those are some of the questions that we
just don't have answers to and we
won't have answers. We just can't have
answers
without following people over time so
it's only something that we will know
after
you know one year or three years how
long that immunity
lasts and if people are really protected
from reinfection or not.
Because we usually use you know
antibodies as kind of a measure of that
but
it's not a perfect correlation. It's
just one of the usually the easiest
things
to measure and kind of most
straightforward things.
So we don't know and that's what
concerns myself and
some other epidemiologists about
like Sweden that is using basically herd
immunity
and protection of elderly
and other vulnerable
populations as their
strategy. You know just let
this come in,
let's get a good population that has
immunity to it
and that's how we'll deal with it. But we
don't know if that'll work.
So we'll be looking at you know
countries who are taking that strategy,
we will be looking at people who have
been known to be infected,
and once we have good antibody tests we
can kind of follow them
over time to see if that immunity
wanes and if so how quickly
or not. So the herd immunity
aspect is something that also
you know we know in theory but whether
that will actually happen
in practice it will be completely due to
like the behavior of this
virus and how it interacts with our
own
immune system.
All right
Let's see.
All right from Rachel Graham: Do you
believe this can be a chronic infection?
We also don't know that.
I think it's unlikely.
Most of the human coronaviruses as
far as we know do not
cause a chronic infection. The common
cold ones or
you know SARS or MERS we haven't seen
that at all.
In the animal coronaviruses there is a
feline one that can cause a chronic
infection
but that seems to kind of be an outlier
and I talked about that a little bit in
the article.
So
I think it's unlikely but you know
with biology with viruses
until you have some evidence I would not
say
completely rule that out,
anything is potential but I
think that is not
something that is going to be likely
with this
virus.
Let's see.
Sorry it's hard to answer and go on
read these questions as well.
So can you explain in simple terms
why COVID-19 wasn't created in the lab?
Maybe I can.
I mean first I think it's unlikely
that
that happened. I know there are some
really big advocates of that
but I think what some people don't
realize is how often these spillovers
from
animals to people happen. Okay so there's
even a term for it
in the field we refer to it as
viral chatter.
So these spillovers from
animal populations to human populations
of
different types of viruses. And so we
know this happens
a lot and most of these spillovers
are not
documented so it often takes something
that is pretty dramatic like
right now like this coronavirus pandemic
or like an Ebola outbreak so
you know something where you have really
clear symptoms
you have a population where you can see
this
going through the people there
and something that comes to the
attention of public health authorities.
So a lot of these
spillovers are often dead ends and
they're either they don't
spread from human to human so they
may go from animal to person but then
not from person to person.
So they die out or they can circulate
maybe undetected for a long time. This is
what happened with HIV.
HIV actually is not a single spillover
event. It didn't happen just once it
happened multiple times with related
viruses.
That's why they're slightly different
they came from slightly different
animals
from you know chimpanzees to sooty
mangabeys to gorillas
that independently went from
those animal reservoirs into the human
population and then
spread from there but again we didn't
detect them initially because they don't
cause
like you know symptoms as
obvious maybe as Ebola.
And they happened in populations that
were you know not being carefully
monitored,
you know in many cases it was before
we had a lot of
the science to be able to detect them so
you know that's why HIV and aids
wasn't found until the 1980s in the
United States when it hit populations
that you could see okay something weird
is happening here
in these populations. But some of the
earliest
viruses crossed over into human
populations you know almost a century
before that
and had been spreading undetected. So
that's a long introduction into
saying that I think it's
it's just based on how everything works
it is much more likely that this is a
natural spillover than
something created in a lab. Looking at
its genome sequence it doesn't have any
markers
of being you know altered by
humans. I know and after that was kind
of
pointed out the other idea came that
well okay but it was in the lab
and then it had just gotten loose from
there which
is tougher to rule out but if so it
was not a virus that ever was recorded
as being in that laboratory, it was never
identified or sequenced
so and you know we,
I can't say lab accidents never happen
but they're certainly much less common
than just those natural spillovers from
wildlife reservoirs or other animal
reservoirs into humans.
So you know I think
it's tough to prove a negative but I
think it's much more likely that it
was a natural event
than some kind of a laboratory
accident right. So maybe we'll do one
final one here.
Let's see.
Is the idea that viruses
evolve to become
less pathogenic a rule of thumb?
And that is one thing that that
certainly people have
put forward about this virus in
particular and about viruses in
general and it's not. I mean it's…
People see that we have identified
multiple
mutations in
coronavirus lineages and I think people
hear mutation and associate that
with meaning as far as
changing pathogenicity, either making it
worse or making it
you know less serious. That's not
necessarily the case. You can have
mutations that just do nothing. That's
most of the mutations right.
And there's this idea that if
something
you know jumps from again maybe a
non-human
reservoir into people that over time
if it co-evolves
with humans that it will become
you know mild or asymptomatic and
that can happen sometimes but it's not
something that necessarily happens. Again
we had Ebola in west Africa
that went through many many many
chains of transmission
from 2013 to 2016 before we were
finally able to
extinguish that outbreak. And there
was really no
evidence over that period of time that
it was becoming less pathogenic.
Mortality rates decreased in some cases
but that seems to be more related to
getting good care, just getting good
supportive care and not to any actual
properties of the virus itself.
So with viruses and with
you know evolution like that there's
really no hard and fast rules,
there's always lots of
maybe general outcomes but even that
doesn't always… you know there are always
exceptions that prove the rules right.
So I don't think we should assume
that this is going to become
less pathogenic or anything or evolve in
some certain trajectory we just
I think really don't know right now. And
it will depend on
a ton of different factors including
whether it's you know maybe
recombines with other coronaviruses
or whether it sticks to itself or if
it just
hits on any particular mutations that
would make it more fit and whether those
mutations would make it
more or less pathogenic, again I don't
think we
can necessarily foresee that right now.
All right so with that
let's see here I think I will
kind of stop this right now and thank
you all for joining me, for tuning
In. For those of you who may have come
into this
midway or if you missed this on
the first round
this will be on Quanta's YouTube
channel at some point so keep an
eye for that.
You can also subscribe to their
YouTube channel and if
you want to learn more about other
developments in epidemiology and biology
and math and physics and all the other
things that
that Quanta covers then please
check out QuantaMagazine.org
and subscribe to their YouTube channel
where they have a lot of other
Q and A's with other scientists as
Well. Right
so thank you for joining and stay safe
out there, take care of each other,
have a good afternoon. Thank You.